- Wow.
- A true selfless act
always sparks another.
(children laughing)
- Dear Mr. Klaus, instead of
stealing Mrs. Runa's berries
we picked them all up for her.
She came to our house
later and she brought mom
lots of berry jam.
And then mom brought her a berry pie.
- Forgive me I'm kind of a dreamer but
isn't that why we do it?
Why you became a teacher?
So you could make a difference?
- Oh!
(chalk scrapes)
- There you go.
- Really, that's my name?
- Yes, yay it's your name.
- Wow, can you teach me more?
Please.
- [School Children] Me next
I want to write my name.
Pick me, pick me, teach
me how to write my name.
♪ If happy lives a mile away ♪
♪ A couple steps is all it takes ♪
♪ If kindness lives in everyone ♪
♪ Then all it takes is standing up ♪
♪ Can't touch it, see it ♪
♪ But you can always feel it ♪
♪ The greatest things you never ♪
- (speaking foreign language)
♪ Can't touch it ♪
♪ See it ♪
- [Klaus] Delivering these toys,
seeing the joy they bring to children,
I thought I'd never feel this again.
- [Young Man Voiceover]
What am I supposed to do?
Stay forever in this little town?
Hanging out with an old woodsman.
Surrounded by crazy people.
Never wanting anything more.
- Mine?
- [Long Haired Girl] So
when you go to sleep,
and when you wake up in the morning,
the present is right
there by the fireplace.
- Ya Mr. Klaus is amazing.
- [Little Girl] Ya he's awesome.
- Klaus, awesome?
- He's huge, but he can
squeeze down any chimney.
- Really, how?
- I don't know, magic I guess.
- [Little Girl] Oh and he likes cookies
don't forget to leave out some cookies.
- He came, he came!
- Mines the big one.
- I told you, I told you he would come!
- Mom, come here quick!
Yes it's just what I wanted.
(excited children cheering)
- I'm coming love.
- [Voiceover] I stopped
trying to make sense of it
a long time ago.
What I do know is that once a year
I get to see my friend.